well anti-virus software no longer works
I don't want the as the feds busting
down my doors so if you have a computer
and you have any kind of antivirus
software on your computer that says
McAfee I am sitting with the founder of
that antivirus software John McAfee and
a few other things to tell you about
John before we get into it he's probably
got one of the most I mean there's so
many ways stories you read about him
that's just so interesting when you read
about him former presidential candidate
I think when you ran you ran on a
libertarian slash cyber party it was a
limited year Libertarian Party 1987
founded McAfee and in 1996 t-cells had
made a lot of money at that time if
social media was around 1994 1996 he'd
probably you probably have tens of
millions of people following you on your
you know views that you have in place so
again I can say a lot of things about
yourself you say let's just keep it
simple and get into it
John thank you so much sir for taking
the time for visiting with us truly
appreciate it if we can get right into
it you know so right now you know you
saw what happened with last week two
weeks ago everybody's curious to know
what's going on with Mark Zuckerberg
Facebook all of these other things and I
know you yourself having been on the
other side when you're running the
software and you kind of trying to
protect us and in a space like that one
you were running at McAfee was known as
probably number one because it was ran
by people who were extremely paranoid
which is what you would want so when you
see that today and you see what's going
on with Facebook what are you thinking
about
well I'm thinking people are foolish if
you believe you can go onto the internet
sign-on to a social media site and
expect to have privacy
that's ridiculous how do these companies
make money seriously Google Google makes
money by knowing where you are what you
behind who you is who your contacts are
who your let's talk to you where you're
eating your your dinner this is how
everybody makes money and to think that
you're going to get these free services
seriously how valuable to you is Google
how often do you google something to
find out anything you know we're the
next clothing super squats on the movies
you know something to help your children
with their homework constantly
invaluable or does it cost you
zero zero please nothing is free nothing
is free I mean my parents told me that I
told my children that what you are
paying is your privacy please
so to be shocked that Facebook is
selling your data or allowing people to
have access to it I'm sorry this is
foolish it's utterly foolish so if you
want to use free services and you're
paying nothing for them why then are you
upset that they're taking the data that
you input in selling it I mean to expect
privacy in this world where hackers can
see anything the government can see
anything that our telephones our of our
smartphones are designed to spy on us
that serves they're designed pardon
they're designed to spy on us of course
they are because how again do they make
money the they have application
interfaces that let them access your
location your contacts who you're
calling what you're buying
why because marketers pay a lot of money
for that no that's okay if in fact all
you get from that is someone trying to
sell your shoes but when hackers use
those same facilities or the government
then we lose our privacy we have people
watching us because these operating
systems are designed to find out as much
about you as possible
did you watch the congressional hearing
no I acted it would be nonsense hey Mark
Zuckerberg got nothing to do with it
it's ourselves you know we we want
everything and we expect everything well
the world doesn't work out interesting
different point of view you know I don't
think it's a different I think that most
technologists would agree with me that
you know once you log on to the internet
your privacy is gone so you have a
choice keep your privacy or go okay well
I'm gonna be very careful about what I
input you know people ask for my
I just don't give it to them in a
certain information you do not get and
if I cannot get on to your site then
I'll go somewhere else so the only are
you pretty active on all social media
sites right normally just Twitter are
you active on all social sites or -
where's quick account I'm not too active
on I have a youtube channel
mostly it's Twitter most least Twitter
okay
so whatever Mark Zuckerberg said or
doesn't you know the informations going
to be used you know for whatever
organization is going to contact and so
that's a consumer needs to know that if
you're gonna do it if you don't want to
do it get off and don't share your stuff
with people that they can use against
you right okay don't get on social media
sites but they are valuable so be me I
don't expect privacy I was not at all
surprised at that Facebook you don't
expect privacy of course I don't I mean
if I want privacy I have to take care of
it
I have to be careful about what I input
I have to be careful about what what
media sites I'm young what machine I'm
using to access those sites if you input
your name and your address your age you
better expect everybody in the world to
have access to that whatever you put
down on any media site you must expect
the entire world to see that so I'm very
careful at what I put down do I care if
the world noses no if I do care and then
I don't go on so so let me ask you when
you were running McAfee for that from 87
and 94 until you resigned that seven
year period was there ever times when
somebody really tried to break into a
computer system of somebody's and you
got alerted where you were so concerned
we said I got to pick up the phone and
call the NSA or FBI did that ever happen
all the time all the time said I was
enorm
well of course I mean that was that was
on viruses the first coming out and they
were destroying people's systems you
know destroying all of your data doing
terrible things so of course when you
got it into corporations people were
losing corporations were losing millions
of dollars so of course they call the
FBI gotta if you don't mind us going
back who were you in high school I'm
just really curious if I went to high
school with you in tenth grade junior
year who was John McAfee in high school
I don't know I was a crazy character I
got almost straight A's I studied hard
and did not go out for sports that was
it I was a nerd truly you weren't hurt
so you were not Hardy and you didn't
have the girlfriend you weren't playing
a sport friends yeah I mean nerds had
girlfriends back then I know if you're
smart
got it so after high school you know um
when I when I study some of this things
things that you you pursued you were I
think you were Xerox Lockheed and you
were nestled right prior to starting a
McAfee so at what point you said you
know I just think I want to start this
antivirus software what inspired you
want to start McAfee although that was
sort of an accident you know I had I was
living with our brother-in-law
in Santa Clara California and he was
reading the local newspaper about this
thing called brand-new thing computer
virus and he was reading it out loud get
me that paper so I could read the
article I thought good lord what is this
thing I mean a virus it could replicate
itself live moving from one machine to
another
well that was fascinating so I said I
thought about it how on earth could
someone do this and then it occurred to
me how they did it and at the same time
it occurred to me how I could stop it so
I just wrote a little program and I ran
a bulletin board system that was
bulletin boards were the precursor to
the Internet you know I had 16 phone
lines coming into my house I mean I
could only have 16 simultaneously users
but people would download software from
one bulletin board uploaded to another
and in a matter of days millions of
people could could access things sorry I
wrote a little program and two weeks
later revived me and people were using
it two weeks later two weeks later 1987
two weeks later five million people were
using it yes you saw that kind of growth
in two weeks yes
that is unbelievable that is
unbelievable well I was the only one
that had a program for it at that time
at that time and so immediately
everybody said I need to have someone
like this to protect myself everybody
right God and I thought that was that
was that was the end of it but then two
weeks later another virus occurred
called The Jerusalem virus and then it
just started coming a hot and heavy and
I had to keep updated with all these
viruses so pretty soon everybody was
using the mcafee virusscan
unbelievable how this whole thing gets
started
so an accident or it's a purely accident
yeah well I don't expect anything to
happen I thought well he was worried run
this program when you were going at that
time were you connected with the jobs
and the gates was there a relationship
there or not at all and where you were
completely that time not at that time
kada and and uh didn't intel end up
buying McAfee in 2011 for some seven
point seven billion I think forty eight
dollars a share some number like that
and now today you can't get on a
computer without seeing McAfee someone
that's your last name that's your name
that's all over the place and so today
you know you hear and you read up on it
how do you feel about the product now
since you've been away from it since
1994 what do you think about the product
not twenty four years later well
antivirus software no longer works that
paradigm that I invented does not work
in the modern world of the internet and
hackers and social engineering new
hacking techniques have obviated virus
scanning software that it's simpler it's
non functional yet everybody continues
to buy it because that's all that they
know but the paradigm is is passed and I
was the first to say it you know five
years ago I went public and said
virus scan software is useless it cannot
protect us from modern modern threats it
cannot protect us ramada so what how do
we protect ourselves today well if it's
not the question I mean most hacking is
social engineering which is which is
problematic meaning it's it's using
people rather than hacking into a system
and trying to find passwords you start
calling secretaries or people in the
company and you have a story and they
suddenly give you the information rather
than you having to hack into it yourself
this is 99% of all hacks today 99% of
all this today got it so meaning that no
matter what I do if somebody really
wants to infiltrate my system and get
the information they want out of me
there's really not much I can do about
it no didn't you say you designed a
phone that's hack meaning hack proof
nobody can hack the phone that's great
is that phone out for people to buy it
or not yet exactly well it was being
done through MGT I resigned from MGT a
couple months ago because I was a boy
it was you know I moved totally into
cryptocurrency but yeah the phone is
it's pretty much haqq/truth pretty much
all decloak phone and it should be
coming out in six months so somebody
could buy it six months from now it's
eight so they said it will not be my
phone anymore belong to mgj TV so you
know there was a book written in the 80s
called
only the paranoid survive do you
remember that book I don't is it
it was actually written by the founder
of Intel only the paranoid survive do
you think in a world like this it
benefits maybe not even benefits it
behooves people to be a little bit more
paranoid than they usually are you know
I think I think paranoia serves its
purpose I mean it's paranoia makes you
more aware of threats it makes you pay
attention I wouldn't say people should
be paranoid people should be cautious
people should be aware that you need to
be aware of the threats you need to be
aware that when you log on to the
internet your expectation of privacy is
absurd you're logged on to a system
where there are two billion computers
attached you know billion people who are
for interfacing and communicating and
watching you know a million hackers
trying to steal money family or
information or to find something that
they can blackmail you with this is the
world that you enter when you log on to
to the Internet and if you enter that
world thinking I'm perfectly safe the
the world will take care of me well who
the hell is going to take care of you I
mean it's my soccer Bergkamp Facebook
and Twitter can't Google can't I mean
Twitter they if you go on to Twitter
they're probably 200 John McAfee zall
with my picture and everything else
they're they're all fake and this is in
the news a couple of weeks ago Twitter
has tried to stop this and cannot too
many people are doing it they they
stopped one thing they they coming
through another avenue that kinda
members a different ID but the same
photos how do you feel about it well no
feelings no emotions or you either
accept it or it is what it is what it is
it cannot be fixed Jesus live with it so
you think we're going in the direction
of living a naked life which means you
know I can you know nowadays I can go
online within a five minute period I can
find out if you're a Democrat Republican
what sports team you like married kids
how many kids age you know issues
frustrations you can pretty much find
that if somebody goes on there spends
five minutes do you think we're going in
the direction where we are accepting our
privacy being taken away from us I
expect mine to be taken away well I
expect everything that I put into the
internet to be taken away if you put it
on the Internet someone's gonna get it
it's a fact of life there's no way to
prevent it so what you put into it you
better expect the world to know so I use
disinformation you know for example I I
bought a house and a new place in a
foreign country and I said it was in
Dominica put photographs in no no I've
never been to Dominica and I do not have
a house sir
however those people who are trying to
find me are working for me I mean you
know you have to figure it out yourself
protect yourself by any means possible
disinformation no information limited
information but whatever you put into
the internet it's it's gone man people
gonna be looking at it and reading and
then watching it John when you were
running McAfee did because this becomes
one of my concerns you know how they say
whenever you have a computer and you got
the camera on the Apple computer covered
up and put a tape on it yourself so they
can't see you because they're watching
you all these other conspiracies that
you have to be looking out for when when
you went from zero to five million
customers have an interest on the
product your marketing within two weeks
d-did at that time the government a
government agency reached out to you
when they wanted to get information on
other people did they contact you did
you ever have moments where their
contact you knew saying hey we want to
know a little bit more about XYZ thing
is I didn't know about XYZ I was not in
the business of gathering information on
my customers I didn't know who they were
it was they downloaded it for free it
was free to start with I only knew who
someone was if they called because they
got a virus sorry I didn't have a
database I had nothing I could give to
the government no every
about any government did in fact contact
me because they're all concerned about
viruses and the government was my first
major customer all aspects the Defense
Department the personnel department
everything so the US government became
really my largest customer for the first
year but I didn't have anything to give
them I didn't have anything that's a I
knew nothing they were just using your
services what they were using no nobody
using my software but back then software
didn't send home where it was located
who was using it because there was no
value in it interesting so then there
was we didn't sell information because
there were no buyers for it because no
one had it back Tina's sell information
because it was a buys for pardon there
was no buyer sport first of all we
didn't have it even if we had it people
didn't know what to do with it back then
it was it was a it was a brand new field
personal computers had just entered the
world a couple of years before so are
you certain like if you were to bet on
this one here are you certain that if a
government agency is a government agency
involved with a Google or Facebook or
some of these guys to get I mean that
smile says a lot but a you certain
certain of it that is taking place ah
absolutely yes please Lord would any
government allow Google Facebook Twitter
the can that has massive amounts of
information on everybody not just in
America but in the world do you think
they would allow that just to free go on
it on its way of course not please Lord
this is how governments work you think
I'm paranoid governments are paranoid
they're all terrified of losing power of
change of revolution of the world
turning upside down so of course I mean
it makes it only makes sense if they are
not I then I don't understand reality I
don't understand how the world so you
are for what they're doing no I'm not
saying for it I'm just saying of course
they're doing it I'm not saying I'm for
it
I'm absolutely against it so what's an
ideal situation I mean if they if
they're worried about revolution or a
turning upside down what is the
alternative not doing anything about and
leaving it alone well I mean you can you
can you can worry about
these things or or you can actually spy
on your people to make sure it doesn't
happen
I'd much rather not worry about either
one let's just continue as America or is
this London or as Australia and and just
let thing has happened I don't I don't
believe that a government that spies on
its people is gonna stop people getting
angry upset or wants to change the
government I just think about it this
way I've you know because what you just
said right now I'm processing that I'm
thinking about it so if if you're gonna
come to fight me tonight and I'm gonna
bring ten of my guys you're gonna bring
ten of your guys and we're meeting in
pic at Clarksville Kentucky okay or
Clarksville Tennessee and you know I'm
coming with you know semi-automatic
weapons I got guns and you're coming
with your you know okay I'm a man's man
I'm just gonna fight you with my knuckle
you know I'm just gonna fight you here
my bare knuckles I mean you know who's
gonna win that fight even though it's
ten against us so if it's me I'm not
gonna go I'm gonna have a dinner with
somebody you do have that choice right
but the point I'm trying to make is if
the government says well you know we're
just not gonna do we leave everybody to
themselves a citizen is gonna do it and
if a citizen does that those gonna do
what they're gonna try to go take some
kind of control and you know hack into
people's decision-making process and see
what they're doing wouldn't that be
happen if it isn't already of course
that's happening that's what the hackers
is doing constantly I mean let's just
look at some of the major hacks now two
and a half years ago someone took 21
million records from the United States
first Office of Personnel Management
that means everybody with top-secret
clearances everybody who has ever worked
for the US government for the past 50
years good God Almighty
do you realize what a what a major coup
that would have been in a war an act of
espionage of the scale of which has
never been attempted and it's you know
some random person and in Russia or
China probably wandered and it just took
it it's so easy to do is that why you
ran for presidential you know for
president to be a president because you
said I think I heard you say one time
what we are worried about a nuclear war
is a last thing to worry about what we
need to be worrying about is a cyber war
yeah is that what you're referencing
that
possibly that could happen one day well
of course I think it's happening today I
think it's already happening we're just
since it is a cyber war we're not gonna
see it we're just gonna see little
little evidences here and there because
seriously a cyber war would be a very
inexpensive war I mean Korea has 2100
hackers it's a group of government
hackers with the capacity to literally
take down any country in the world
including the US by any number of ways
hacking into our power grid shunting the
electricity in such a way that all of
our Transformers burn out across America
now we have no electricity how do you
repair it I don't know all of our of all
of our repair tools are electrically
operated everything goes south we don't
have any electricity to run the plants
to create the food and can demand ship
them so that we can eat we don't have
the the electricity to create fuel from
raw oil we have no nothing to run our
cars on we have no lights we have no
heat hospitals are down we have no
emergency services think about it now
there's no nuclear war they're gonna
ever achieve that there would always be
pockets of we would still have something
but no so if you were to if you were
running for office let's just say you
ran for office and you got elected over
Trump okay your president what are you
doing to make sure that doesn't happen
well you know number one I I had no
intention of ever getting elected no one
in the right mind I mean I could never
get elected president however running on
the libertarian platform it gave me a
forum that allowed me to speak and to
tell what I think the problems in
America are and that's that's all I
asked for and that's what I achieved but
boy if I was in Trump's position I
wouldn't I wouldn't have a clue I mean
they'd have a clue I wouldn't here and
here's why it is I mean I saw you when
you were talking about this it sound
like you were pretty you said and I
think you were speaking to was a lyric
it wasn't Larry King it was it was
somebody from Fox you were speaking you
said look I'm not just running because
I'm running I'm running because I really
feel this is an important issue with
cyberwar and I feel I know what it takes
to be able to help you know improve
this situation so well we're talking
about one thing that cyberwar itself
yeah number one I would fire every every
technician in the US government because
it would hang on their every government
agency and every country in the world
becomes a magnet for people who want
stability want continuity wants security
these aren't the people who design new
creative innovative systems now there
are the people that maintain the status
quo well the status quo is all [ __ ] up
hmm
so no we we number one get rid of
everybody know that that's gonna be very
hard number to restructure I would I
would go out and I would go to places
like DEFCON where all the hackers go to
conventions put up a US government booth
think we're hiring alright and I'd hire
the people that we're trying to fight
and they don't look like government
employees these guys man smoke weed on
the job you know and they have Mohawks
and and Pierce tongues and that's they
know whether they want yeah I could care
what people look like or how they act if
they can do the job and so so that's not
going to happen either I mean it's one
thing to say on Larry King or yes I know
what to do but in reality in reality I
mean that's politics that's the ability
for Viggo I want to listen to what he
says next but in reality it's it's a
morass of of intertwined tiny evils of
the the tiny evils of Google and
Facebook we call them evils they you
know the the fact that we have no
privacy the fact that people are spying
the fact that the hackers can get into
anything and steal what they want the
fact that our financial system is is
very fragile in terms of factors really
wanted to attack America a couple of
thousand could bring us down financially
why don't they we probably have the
ability to do the same thing to them but
know this this is you know we have let
things get out of control and we've done
it because we are lazy we are you know
why do we accept smart phones that have
the capacity find my location turn on my
camera turn on my microphone look at my
contacts see
I'll ask alt find out what I'm buying on
Amazon or what have you
why do we accept that because this makes
our life easy so you want to make your
life easier you you don't want you
probably don't remember time where phone
numbers were in your head what was your
grandmother's phone number you know it
right off the bat
do you know anybody's phone number now
other than your own and maybe your
wife's I'm a math guy so for me I do but
most people don't I fully understand
what you're saying
Thanks pretty well for most people you
know contacts and I click that and so
that's that it's a great boon a great it
makes life easier
nothing is free again what do you think
that costs us let me let me ask you this
do you think we're going to so first of
all before me even asking this do you
think the election still is being
controlled by the people voting so do
you think we voted for or is there
enough you know it's a little minute
later I'm on camera and you know I don't
want the the feds busting down my door
but but no I don't think we do control
who gets into office I think we are
deluding ourselves if we think that the
voting booths the unions the local
people who control the voting process do
you think that if that is truly
absolutely 100% secure honest and not
tamper Abul with I am sorry if you're
absolutely wrong and so if it can be
tampered with if it can be in any way
manipulated and it will be this is human
nature so to think again that we
actually have control and we're electing
our presence you might question that if
I were you I would I would seriously
question the reality of our voting
system at this pace that we're going do
you think we're gonna get to a point
where a 35 year old person or 36 your
personal is going to end up becoming the
president because they have a better
easier way of what do you call it have
an easier way of you know key words you
know advertising putting ads up and they
get the word out in a boom I got a
36-year president because he knows how
to be in the face
more than somebody else does you what is
Donald Trump doing now what is his is
his main tool for communicating with
America used to be the media you Collins
ever have a news conference see know
what does he tweet something he tweets
something anybody was with 25 million
followers on anything whether it's
Facebook or Twitter or you name it good
lord you have tremendous power and you
have tremendous influence because you
have the ear of your followers so of
course this can happen so do you think
we're going in the direction of the
person that has the most followers ends
up becoming a president has the most
salient might be it might be might be we
look we're no longer it would reach the
point where we're voting we go let's
count okay so and so's got 131 million
then you're the president Wow so you
know I'm being facetious yeah no I get
what you're saying no not really and to
some degree can you not see that this is
this is a possibility so would that mean
that we would need to possibly possibly
reconsider our voting system if that's
the direction we're going because
somebody that has more reach you know
has a bigger voice that can get to a
bigger platform even if somebody else
has more sound values that's going to
help protect the country better I don't
think we will actually reach that point
because before then all of our board
voting will become electronic okay
computer controlled at that point it's
the programmer who programs these
computers that will choose our
presidents I'm telling you the truth I
mean that's a concern though just please
God see you see the truth of this
because these are complex systems yeah
designed by hundreds or sometimes
thousands of people the man or woman who
understands the the internals the
connections the the the subroutines the
flow of logic the the most you can put
anything you want in there
it can't be discovered it it's too
complex way to con the bed they're
they're called backdoors for hackers for
this I don't know what you're gonna call
it but you could put in there's
something where were you
Thank You Jimmy where you say okay well
you know we're gonna decide who we want
to have present and when voting comes
I'm just going to tell all my machines
you know give 51% to this person there's
49 to that person
yeah trivial that would be that's what
I'm saying I mean if that's the
direction we're going to right now we're
the person with the biggest following
ends up winning you know then there may
be a time that we need to reconsider
ways and by the way just out of
curiosity how do you feel as it's just
so viewer knows and I know how do you
feel about Trump as a president himself
I like to okay god you're not saying
anything we're indirectly we're taking a
shot at Trump saying because he's got a
lot of followers became a president I
think first of all I think the the
Twitter move was very smart he bypasses
because presidents are held hostage by
the media you gets into a press
conference they get to edit what they
want they get to put in their their own
skew their own color their own flavor to
what you have said but you can do it
easily enough for simply cutting things
out we organizing things in terms of
time sequence or whatever or focusing on
the biggest faux pas that you made well
know if you are doing it yourself in
these tiny bites of you know a hundred
and two hundred and eighty characters
the media is locked out the media is
shut out
they have no more power no more control
thank God for that they hate that thing
well good they said you know no no no
disrespect to you and and you guys but
honestly this is what is wrong with this
country
and every country the the information
flow funneled through a few faces a few
of agencies a few stations Fox CNN CNBC
that's the problem
because if you watch the news is it news
and some stations are women with with
leather you know leather vest and
low-cut blouse [ __ ] this is all it's
a drama
it's entertainment is its self you know
self aggrandizement by the news anchors
who do you actually listen to is there
anybody where you say I
I respect on value this person's opinion
anybody in the media day say disguise
half-decent when he talks know nobody
nobody so your value in everything
that's happening you're trying to see
what he you know motive behind it is or
how do you and take it because again
going back to it going back to it you
know like I said earlier we trusted
McAfee because the guy running the it
was extremely cautious and paranoid and
he had to make sure that hey you pay me
for this service because you don't have
to worry about somebody hacking your
computer because I know exactly how
hackers thing so we said here you go
eighty nine bucks here you go six nine
dollars we trust you keep doing what
you're doing as somebody that is as
paranoid in its wire the way you are I
mean we're sitting in a place you got
people protect and you've got you got a
piece on the side so it's not like we're
you know you know it's totally fine I
was in the military so we're sitting
here and you know a you are pretty
protective of your personal life and
your liberties and the choices that
you're making but knowing that and if
this is what we're going I mean what is
the real solution to it you know that
that I am protecting myself I have I
have hired my security I am carrying the
piece I have structured my life to
protect myself the step one is don't ask
someone else to do it for you don't
expect the government don't expect
you're police short they are designed to
do this but if someone breaks into my
house puts a gun to my head is there a
magic button that I can push that makes
the policeman immediately materialized
between me and the attacker no please
God they are there they're not there to
protect him knows his protect and serve
they come in after the mess clean up and
try to find the perpetrator and
prosecute him that's what this is all
about nobody's protecting you you want
Mark Zuckerberg to protect your privacy
good god please
he has no capacity to do so neither is
it his job right it's our jobs as
citizens to make sure we take care of
ourselves that's that's as I see it yeah
if you're over the age of 21
then please God don't expect someone
else to make your decisions to weigh the
alternatives to protect yourself and
your family it's your responsibility so
so let me ask you did you so again
follow up on this would you consume your
information from or do you at all
consume any
do you consume any information yourself
I get it straight from the source if I
can I mean if I you know if if they're
if they're reporting on something that's
happening in the Middle East I'm gonna
go to a Middle East station a Middle
East newspaper and find out from them
their their their their gutter you get
your source let's let's get it from
multiple sources balance them out but in
most cases I just don't care because
it's all the same would you like this
one here six yeah always so in 1986
you're not consuming any content
opinions you know Walter Cronk somebody
sent Buckley or good that vedalam
or not no not that I did not keep my ear
to the ground but I was concerned with
computer viruses and security all those
people I definitely I was listening to
them what did you discover yesterday
what about this virus where do you think
this is going do you think I'll let me
tell you why please I don't want to
sound cynical and and obtuse but what is
the purpose of the media is it not to
make money mysteriously please God
whoever you work for they're expecting
you to make money how do you make money
by creating the most interesting content
if it's news the most interesting story
if it's not interesting you damn well
better make it interesting and how do
you make it interesting you find some
perspective some weird strength
perfectas I look at this from this angle
what a horrible person want a horrible
event
why because I thought we're traveling
down the highway and there's a massive
accident what happens everything stops
withstand so we all want to see it as
though the grandmother baking pies by
the highway do we give a [ __ ] no we do
not
it's human nature and so in order to
make money which is your job this you're
doing this to make money are you doing
this for free this I'm not making money
on I run a financial firm this is just a
YouTube channel we have I don't work for
Fox and I'm gonna ban see you expect to
make money off of this somehow oh no
that'll break for ya director sure
absolutely I mean it's like you running
McAfee right you're running it to make
money but partially I agree with what
you're saying on the part that and so
that's one the reasons why I'm asked you
know I'm asking you to know if
somebody's watching the scene so what
give my source where I can see you know
my opinion is always watched both sides
to kind of get the argument if
somebody's building this side up study
the others have somebody's building to
side up watch the other side but how do
you know what information is coming
maybe someone doesn't have your line a
resource common sense so let's start
with the fact that they're there to make
money so obviously you're going to try
to beef up your story in such a way that
you make the most money how you do that
you get the most views how do you get
the most views to have the most radical
story or the most unusual thing anybody
would disagree with that I think a so
let's start with this let's start with
that so I'm watching the news and
somebody says something and they're
focusing on this my first question is
that doesn't sound right I'm sorry it
just doesn't sound like human nature I
mean because what is human nature we are
loving people we are we are hopeful we
have dreams and and we are compassionate
we have grace but then we also have
anger and fear are we jealous people
aren't we greedy people I'll take that
package and you put that inside or put
that in the guy who's telling you the
story because that's who's telling the
story the guy who has thank you sir the
guy who has grace compassion fear
jealousy and greed
okay that's he's telling the story each
of these things are gonna manifest in
the story you're getting a story through
this man you're not getting the story
the story would be the man just shutting
the shutting up and just showing videos
this this and you figure it out no
instead we have a commentator someone
who will explain this to you you're over
21 do you need self explained to you
please if you do then you know you you
need to do something with yourself if
you don't why are you even watching this
why are you even watching someone tell
you what's really happening so you're
actually saying don't consume content no
what's the point
a complete different perspective
interesting so so let me ask you to
follow up on that do you do you actually
believe that Russia did have any kind of
involvement
or no that's not you to you it's I don't
think Russia had anything to do with the
election
I'm almost certain that Platt least from
a hacking standpoint that Russia had
nothing to do with it from the hacking
stamp on the hacking of the DNC all of
these other things more like no
absolutely why because everything
pointed to the Russians think about it
all right so the DNC they found the
malware it had the Russian language it
had a compile time that matched the
business hours in Moscow it had a
Cyrillic keyboard it was used that's the
Russian keyboard that's that's used to
create the program on and on and on
please God
do you think that anyone in the Kremlin
anybody who is part of the Russian state
no imagine Igor you left your name in
the program
oh yeah I'm sorry boss my my wife was
sick I ran home at lunch I forgot do you
think that actually happens please god
no
you don't leave your language the time
of the compile names the type of
keyboards you use everything that points
to you as Russia do you actually think
the CIA of the NSA would do that yeah
we're gonna hack Russia but we don't
care what what you know leezar leave the
English language in there put Washington
in there no please God you hide it so
you're not gonna do something at that
level something that that horrific and
be lacks about writing the program that
actually does it this is the typical
thing that hackers do to point away from
themselves and toward their worst enemy
kind of like when you said the house you
bought a house recently and you said my
house is located in this area but I've
never been to that place but know why we
don't want people know anywhere yeah so
so it's okay to follow up on that so you
I think at one point you worked with a
Booz Allen as one of the top five
consulting firms and I think Snowden
also worked there at some point he
worked there as well himself obviously
different responsibilities but you know
they have a lot of credibility for what
they do what do you think a Snowden is
or somebody's whistle blow
are for the marketplace do you think
they do good or do you think do you
think they do bad for the information
they're giving it given to us when we
see all of sin you're like oh my gosh
this is really what happened should I
believe it should I not believe it MSNBC
said you shouldn't read it anyways it's
private information it shouldn't be
something you should you should be
embarrassing yourself you read oh you
should read it what do you think about
us snowed in the marketplace first and
foremost you're taking Snowden the
definition the the character that the
person has created by the media as the
truth that he in fact did well he didn't
think we're for his own he was a
whistleblower if he ended up in Russia
tada tada do you guys how many other
alternatives there are they yes that he
still works for the CIA and this is some
massive disinformation thing that is
keeping the world occupied while the CIA
does something totally different you
think that's not a possibility do you
think there are 10,000 there are 10,000
different ways we can define what Edward
Snowden is and why he did what he did is
it good for the market well hell yes
anything that brings attention to any
specific area of life is good for that
area of life that's a fact of life
be whether it's good or whether it's bad
I mean the PT Barnum said it the best
there is no such thing as bad press if
they spell your name right because in
the end people remember the name and
everything else gets lost in the shuffle
of life but yes to the read into it is
that is that a good thing is is it is is
me the the the person that's trying to
use my common sense to come up with a
proper opinion an educated opinion
should I take his information and say
I'm gonna consider this when it comes
out to poll time to vote if you think is
about sebuah then you would take that
information and use it for the good if
you think it's it's disinformation there
was planned
ten years ago by the CIA and Edward
Snowden is one of these great actors
I mean first and foremost please why
didn't anybody ask how he ended up in
Russia if you could make him watch
things he was in Hong Kong alright I was
in Hong Kong I was really on the run
I've just fade into the
countless of Hong Kong I'm a technician
you know grab some cute little you know
Hong Kong girl and get an apartment
somewhere and live happy ever after but
he was on his way to Ecuador keep this
in mind was he not mm-hm he was on his
way to Ecuador why Ecuador's the place
that once you get there you know you're
not gonna no one's gonna get you out how
from Hong Kong he goes to Russia to then
go to Ecuador and we get to Russia these
not allowed to leave now right off the
bat Meyer you know I travel a lot and I
know the routes that people take if I
want to get to to Ecuador from Hong Kong
the last country in the world I'd go
through is Russia
you've got 50 different options there
you can direct flights makan to Ecuador
why the heck is he going through Russia
so so I you know it's hard for me to say
is it good is it bad I don't have all
the facts and neither do you and neither
do any of you you have the facts that
the media has given you and the story
and the media as we are well aware will
modify stories according to how much
money they're going to make from this
story and destroyed so you know James
Comey just came out with a new book it's
called a higher loyalty what do you
think about James Comey in this whole
situation you know one minute he's
saying here's what happened another
minute he's saying that's what happened
what do you think about James comers
position right now or do you have an
opinion on it at all I only have
opinions on things I have personal
experience with my only personal
experience with James Comey is a year
and a half ago when the FBI wanted a
master key for the the iPhone that was
taken from the shooter in California he
he the quote terrorists one of the
master key yeah I got up in arms because
that would be the worst thing that ever
happened in the world and so on a
Wednesday and this is all documented on
a Wednesday out of 15-minute debate with
the James Rogers who is the mouthpiece
of the FBI one of the
just characters I've ever come up
against so we had a 15 minute debate but
but I really researched his background
no way to win a debate on his terms and
and because he comes in saying you want
privacy or security so I changed the
debate at the at the table and said well
I'm not I don't know anything about
privacy versus security I wish I did we
could talk about it but I'm one I'd like
to talk about security versus less
security because if you get a master key
America's gonna be less secure okay so
that sort of threw him off and at the
end he said well maybe we can work
together okay that was on a Wednesday on
a Monday James Comey and by the way I
said please give me the phone I will
unlock it and give it back to you
tomorrow I said that publicly more times
than than once
everybody knew on Monday James Comey is
testifying in Congress the specific
question was mr. Comey have you pursued
every offer of help he said yes we have
that sort of [ __ ] nobody ever called
me after that mmm never ever called me
and I'd been talking for two weeks
saying I will unlock the phone so no
they did not pursue my offer of Health
and to think that mr. Comey would not be
aware that I had offered to help after
this CNN you know national broadcast
it's it's it's untenable to think he did
not know that so in Congress he lied he
lied to Congress what an offense that is
in America he said yes sir we have
pursued every avenue not one FBI agent
no one not even a secretary called me to
say well what are your terms can you
really do it no they did not pursue my
offer of help that's all I know about
mr. Comey that's all I can say what
conclusion you come up with that where
do you come up at any consolation the
FBI like any law enforcement agency from
local police on up that has enormous
power will have enormous corruption
I mean power corrupts it does if you if
you don't see that or know that but
please read some of the philosophers or
you know just do
and Google searches power corrupts
absolute power corrupts absolutely
the FBI is a very powerful organization
so of course they have corruption now
it's not Universal it's not every agent
but it's a lot it has to be and it
certainly affected mr. Comey this is all
I know personally about the man this is
not secondhand information this is my
observation having dealt with the FBI at
that level should the average citizen
trust the FBI based on what you're
saying oh the average person Tim trusts
anybody I mean I don't want to be
cynical again but please what does that
mean trust somebody I mean please let's
get down to the nitty-gritty I mean
anybody in a time of war who's ever been
tortured or was a torturer knows the
following you will talk you will turn in
your mother if the pain is intense
enough and long enough this is a fact of
life so do you trust your mother of
course you do to be a mother but what
does that mean trust someone trust
someone walk with your wallet yeah I'd
probably just coming with my wallet I'm
a friend to steal it would be too
obvious trust him with my wife maybe a
little bit less trust him with my life
trust him with what what does that mean
do you trust somebody trust with what
sir because there's no such thing as
trust meaning whatever happens I trust
you in this situation and in all
situations you cannot do that I wish you
could interesting perspective so so
let's let's transition a little bit to
Bitcoin and then and then we'll wrap up
so when it comes to pit Bitcoin you you
know you have been known as one of the
bigger voices if not the biggest voice
in the Bitcoin world and you've said I
think your prediction was by the end of
you think bitcoin is gonna hit 78,000 I
think your projection was 78,000 by the
end of 2018 I think I think you said a
million dollars when I have that I
didn't like the 28th 2018 projection I
made a 2020 production projection of of
1 million I think you said 78,000 to
somebody for
20:18 I remember seeing 78,000 if I'm
wrong you may have seen that then it may
have been written but I promise you I
did not say that quite a few people said
40 $50,000 you're probably even higher
than that in your estimation if it's
going to get to a million by 2020
they're saying 40 $50,000 by the end of
2018 is what many people are expecting
that's no no my my figures at 78,000 by
the end of 2018 yes so are you familiar
with Jordan Bell for the guy the wolf of
Wall Street yeah of course I interviewed
him I was at his place and we were
sitting out talking about Bitcoin and I
said tell me what you think about
Bitcoin and what's gonna happen he says
I am Telling You there are not a lot of
things I have guarantees if I guarantee
you bitcoin is gonna have a sudden from
wherever it's gonna go to all of a
sudden nothing and everyone's gonna lose
their but lose their tail they're gonna
lose everything they have you have a
complete different perspective on bit
for me because the way they describe it
tell me your point of view on Bitcoin
why you think bitcoin is going to go to
million dollars by 2020 Jois to do it
the most common way is to take the
number of users a Bitcoin because as
Bitcoin expands and its user base both
people who who hold the coin and people
who accept the coin for payment its
skyrocketing its skyrocketing so it's
not going to disappear it can't possibly
go to zero it can only grow as the user
base grows so it's impossible Belfort
thought of how smart he is he's wrong he
does not understand digital currencies
and how they worked
listen it's it's Pandora's Box the Box
has been open the spirits are invading
the room and they will not go back in
and you have to believe me
digital currencies will replace fiat
currencies why good god I have a wallet
on my phone which is an entire bank
lending money sending wires I don't have
to go to the bank it takes me 10 seconds
to do a wire
Tim I've got to go down to the bank fill
out a bunch of forms no that's nonsense
other than nonsense do you think that is
going to go to zero and are and we're
going to go back to this incredibly dull
and bizarre way of using money with
please God so I got it I got a rebuttal
for that one a question for you so for
me you know I've been in the financial
industry for a while series 766 I'm you
know I run an insurance company we we do
pretty well for ourselves the part that
concerns me with Bitcoin I I really want
to hear your rebuttal on this when Jamie
diamond is touching 7 trillion dollars
of money per day of transactions that's
not just money that's a lot of political
power but a lot of countries that are
connected to that 7 trillion dollars yes
and so he is one phone call away from so
many different Prime Minister's
presidents kings sheiks whatever you
want to call it because ma he's touching
all these mom and I'm not talking small
money we're talking big money you know
that medicines really seven trillion
there's a lot of money ok so half of our
gross domestic product if if if it goes
in the direction of these 21 million you
know bitcoins being used and for
millions lost I think I don't know the
number that was lost I think it's 4
million of them that was lost some
number like that don't you think a guy
like that and these guys who control
elections and control all these other
things don't you think they're gonna
make a phone call and you know they're
gonna say hey listen mr. congressman mr.
senator you want to do this again don't
make sure you take care of this think
you you cannot let this Bitcoin stuff
take off the way that's this is out of
control already don't you think they're
gonna make those calls to figure out a
way to do what they've always done which
is listen small business owner wants to
compete with the big business owner how
do you beat them very simple big
business owner goes to somebody and
helps them uh financially in a political
side and says listen make the barriers
to enter more difficult how do you do it
more regulations more licensing more
laws more rules more this stuff and so
the new guy cannot come and compete with
this guy he has in a sense a monopoly
with two other companies if you want to
call her monopoly so that is my only
concern with a the argument you're
making is but you're assuming that
Congress make whatever laws they want
obviously they can outlaw Bitcoin they
can about go on you're assuming that
there is a possibility of enforcing
those laws that's utter [ __ ] nonsense
you cannot stop a distributed system
that is worldwide there is no law that
you can make if you had one person per
for citizen in the country 400 million
enforcers you still couldn't do it well
because you unfortunately have to sleep
for some at some point it's not possible
okay
no admittedly the way the things were
six months ago when does when the
exchanges were centralized she could
shut down in exchange you can't do that
anymore
they've now decentralized exchanges you
can't stop it you can't shut it down and
you can't know anything about it
so tell me sir how will you enforce
these magical laws that Congress is
gonna make Jamie Dimon has no power in
this world so let me ask you this then a
follow-up to that you remember what
happened with China
right when the China was going through
there and and Bitcoin dropped I think
from 10,000 to 6,000 I came back up
obviously to 10,000 but it dropped and I
think in in in a event or an interview
you said it dropped that was one of the
reasons because China New Year we know
whatever it is I was linked to that and
and on top of that they made it
difficult for users to use Bitcoin to
buy things okay so go to that choice so
what if somebody says let's make it
difficult for these guys use their
Bitcoin I don't accept Bitcoin so then
what happens to Bitcoin but how are you
gonna make it difficult what are you
gonna do to make it difficult that's why
I just accept it that's fine then you're
not gonna do business because the guy
who does and you're not gonna is even
accepting he's going to advertise on the
dark web if he needs so what if chase
comes and says no problem I want
merchant services authorize that net
they own it I do business but authorize
that net guess what your rates when you
accept money from American Express from
Visa MasterCard is 1.25 you know how the
numbers they have but if you take
Bitcoin six point seven five percent but
the banks doesn't even know what's
happening this is not through the banks
the banks not involved
the bank has nothing to do with this
they don't even see it's it's an
undercurrent because once you get the
exchange is distributed nobody sees it
the banks have nothing to do with it
they but in fact go ahead and do what
you want to get credit card we're not
using credit cards we got bitcoins what
do you need this and that let me explain
to where I'm coming from I own Bitcoin
myself so I'm not coming from a point of
view among that you know I'm just
playing devil's advocate but here's the
misconception the misconception is that
legislation can have teeth it's not
possible this is a distributed war
there is no legislation that can touch
it you can't change it you can't fix it
you can't stop it you can't control it
you can't direct it you have no power I
don't make the laws like whatever you
want it will make no difference you are
that's certain about it I'm gonna
technologist for God's sake we're
talking technology a lot of technology
people have been wrong in the past
before though but you're that's not
wrong without their technology this is
technology I'm telling you something
just like I can tell you antivirus
software does not work because it cannot
stop the hackers in the world I'd say I
said that earlier why because it
technologically can't nothing can know
same thing with Bitcoin you can't stop
Bitcoin this is a fact technologically
impossible cannot be done sir is your
number on the million dollars based on a
map and I know you're a math guy I think
you got a major in mathematics right
yeah I think you got a major mathematics
and as somebody who's a math guy and
your brain is wired everything is math
did you come up with a million dollar
based on a formula or did you come up
with a million dollars of assumption of
what your thing's gonna say I came out
of two ways I looked at the number of
users that user growth
and I chose the main because it has to
be more than a million I can guarantee
it
I came in it that way it came up with
maybe between three and seven million I
came at it through the mining way okay
which I believe is a lot more valid the
last Bitcoin to be mined
okay there's 10,000 - Thank You Jimmy
the difficulty we for that last Bitcoin
is going to be almost infinite
it's going to cost four to five billion
dollars to mine that last coin and mine
isn't gonna do it the value of that coin
has got to be more than the work put
into mine the [ __ ] so if it cost let's
say even 1 billion dollars alright so
one billion dollars the last one well I
should work backwards them there and
find out what the end of 2020 is gonna
be so two ways come up with the same
number between that's five million
there's probably the thing one mean it's
way outside the lower range so I'm very
safe it's it's fascinating watching your
level of conviction
that you have is a fraud I'm a liver
conviction I look at reality is
objectively not with what I wish it
would be but what it actually is and it
is not just Bitcoin I'm talking about
the entire because there are two
thousand other coins before and it's not
not yet
you know Bitcoin it's less than a third
of the total a market cap for
alternative currencies so no you cannot
stop them you cannot change them you
cannot control them accept them and try
to fix your life to get in line with
reality okay so let me ask you this last
question on the topic of Bitcoin
what would your what would your if you
were to be the devil's advocate of that
same exact argument what is the best
argument that you've gotten that's made
you question the Bitcoin side or have
you had any has anybody said anything to
me or one side yet or what what what if
government's don't like it and stop it
okay please you haven't thought that
through people hell no one has ever
shown me a way to stop it they show me
ways to create laws well the good Lord
make all the laws you want we do that
all the time in the 1930s who made it a
law that you could not drink alcohol we
consumed more alcohol per capita during
that periods and in any period in
American history today what are we doing
it's illegal federally and in most
states just smoke weed you finally a
random person that doesn't smoke weed
sir well you don't perhaps but maybe you
do somebody close at a good time with
you guys earlier by the way there's a
really really cool team you got here
well thank you so much for taking the
time I mean I've enjoyed your
perspective on different views that you
have and and it's interesting from the
place that you come and what you've
experienced and if you have actually if
you haven't studied his past and what
he's been a part of you got a pretty
interesting story is it true that
they're thinking about making a movie
about you with Johnny Depp or playing
your part is that actually is that they
got a place that Hollywood Reporter
reported it everyone said that's
actually taking place with Johnny Depp
playing you yeah it was interesting I
was with the Donnie Brasco you remember
Donnie Brasco Joe Pistone we were with
him
couple months ago and Johnny Depp also
played him and our Johnny Depp is
playing you Johnny Depp likes playing
these strange roar
Hunter Thompson and yeah and you know
but if you're gonna have anybody play
maze well be the guy that's the best at
playing those parts I was agreement to
do it you're more of a Morgan Freeman
guy I wanted Morgan Freeman I said I
wanted you and a Morgan Freeman to play
you yeah that would have been very how
he's gonna play that he's a good actor
he's but you could play anything say he
look at his skin color you know how do
you know I'm not black but there's some
skin disease right do you play poker or
no are you a big poker player now I'm
not a big poker player I'll be happy to
play with you I'm sure I would be very
happy to donate my money based on how
you're wired I get a feeling I do thank
you so much for your time really really
truly thank you